ce devait être le jour de l'élection
officielle de joe biden réunis au
congrès des sénateurs et représentants
américains devaient certifier les
résultats du scrutin présidentiel de
2020 avec la victoire du candidat
démocrate
mais cela ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
le chaos s'est installé à washington
des militants du président donald trump
ont envahi le capitole je croyais pas
mes yeux en fait prêter les scènes
hallucinantes seraient listés carré
manchot con
finalement c'était des jamais vu depuis
1814 quand les anglais capitale ces
américains ont brisé les fenêtres du
bâtiment ont occupé et pillé des bureaux
d'élus puis se sont rendus dans les deux
chambres qui forment le congrès le coeur
du pouvoir législatif américain
je pense que joe barton l'a dit bien il
a dit c'est le site abel de la
démocratie c'est le saint des saints
c'est là où les lois du pays sont
promulguées sais c'est juste
inimaginable que ça pu être souillées à
ce point ce sont des imbéciles qui ont
été dirigées parfum inciter à cette
violence point de départ de ce
rassemblement devant le capitole un
discours du président donald trump
devant la maison blanche à la mi journée
nous pouvons descendre nous pouvons
descendre
ceux qui le désirent en direction du
capitole vous devez montrer votre force
et est trop fort face à cette situation
les représentants du parti républicain
en france n'ont pas encore réagi
il annonce vouloir se prononcer par
communiqué de presse